foreign
okay so recently we've seen a few
interesting headlines about apple one
was about them potentially making a
single chip that would combine cellular
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth into one for the
iPhone and then the next day there was a
report that they're working on their own
displays for the Apple watch and the
iPhone and so I've been looking into
this I've been trying to figure out is
this a nothing deal or a massive deal
and so after a lot of research and time
put into this it turns out the best way
to understand this is with a chart see
on the great scale of products that are
made up of a bunch of different parts
there's a gradient and on one half of
that gradient is off-the-shelf parts and
on the other side is fully custom
vertically integrated part now most
smartphones these days have a lot of
things like off-the-shelf camera sensors
from Sony like the Sony IMX 585 that
they'll just sell to anyone there's a
lot of displays out there made by
Samsung and LG but they're calibrated a
bit after you've all heard us talk about
Qualcomm Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 and Qualcomm
has lots of chips that any smartphone
manufacturer can buy and also lots of
smaller parts like fingerprint sensors
and modems and radios from companies
like Qualcomm and broadcom and typically
only when you get to the most specific
parts of the phone like buttons and
Chassis are you going to have custom
parts for your phone now the iPhones
chart right now looks something like
this now most people don't think about
this much but it's actually a cacophony
of different parts it's like a mixed
salad of different things the camera
sensors for example for all intents and
purposes they're just off the shelf from
Sony the main supplier of the battery
for the iPhone is a Chinese company
called amperex but it is customized a
bit it's actually L-shaped and
multi-celled to sort of fit maximally in
the iPhone's design and on the far end
they do have their chassis but also the
fully customized a16 bionic things like
a taptic engine so there is a big
advantage to having parts that are more
custom especially in Tech because the
main benefit that you get is
optimization like for simplicity's sake
just imagine you're trying to build a
triangular object and you want to fill
its volume as efficiently as possible
but you only have square blocks off the
shelf you won't be very efficient with
those parts but if you can design all
the the parts yourself well now we're
talking that's Peak optimization so
clearly you want the the best most well
optimized pieces for your thing your
product you just saw what happened with
the max where they just switched from
all those off-the-shelf Intel parts to
those custom designed Apple silicon
pieces like that was a massive
Improvement for apple and all their
computers took a Quantum Leap Forward in
speed and efficiency in battery life
like they're just hilariously better
than ever before and so the iPhone well
the iPhone is huge for Apple I mean I
know Macs are kind of popular but most
of Apple's Revenue since it came out in
2007 has been from the iPhone so Apple
taking back parts of the iPhone turns
out to be a very Tim Cook supply chain
optimization story more than anything so
there were two stories in there the
displays and the chips let's start with
the displays because as you may or may
not know about 80 percent of iPhone
displays are made by Samsung yeah that's
Samsung and about 12 by LG display and
then the last eight percent by others
like Boe display so right now that
basically looks like Apple going to the
display maker and going hey you guys
make OLED displays right okay cool we're
going to need a bunch of those we would
like you know this curve radius and
these certain cutouts for our little
Dynamic Island and we'd like 100 million
of them so if you guys could do that
that would be great and we'll pay you up
and so that manufacturer based on their
own technology will fill those orders
using the displays they know how to make
and by the way it's actually kind of
super impressive that all this happened
so seamlessly and on the other end you
don't really know if you have a display
made by Samsung or LG or Boe in your
iPhone now if you want to get into the
weeds multiple sourcing is actually a
pretty common tactic to reduce your
Reliance on one manufacturer so
sometimes off the shelf parts from
several different companies are all
pretty similar so for something like the
ambient light sensor for example who
knows who makes that and who cares right
like as long as we get 100 million of
them and they all fit in the iPhone the
same way and they all work then we're
good but it can easily go terribly like
think about the the big differences but
between the Qualcomm powered Samsung
phone and the exynos-powered Samsung
phone or the hardware Lottery back when
we had the Galaxy S8 some of them had
fast storage chips some of them had slow
storage chips so with these iPhone
displays there is some calibration work
that needs to be done but Apple has
handled the sourcing so well that we
never notice the difference so the
question now after seeing these
headlines is what happens when we go
from Apple's displays being slightly
customized to being completely
customized because now there's some
rumors that apple is trying to move from
OLED to micro LED and really stepping up
the design and quality of their displays
and their watches and phones in the next
few Generations so when I first read
into this I actually thought it meant
like nothing like apple doesn't really
actually manufacture pretty much
anything they are a world-class design
firm and they do a lot of research and
design and development but then at the
end of the day when they actually make
the thing they're not manufacturing the
iPhone or the pieces in the iPhone they
get a company to do it they might Custom
Design design the M2 Chip but they're
getting tsmc the actual Foundry to build
the chip for them but it turns out with
micro LED here Apple kind of wants to
put in a ton of the development with the
technology in their own facilities you
know they've already started spending a
ton of money on testing and evolving see
that's the main difference before they
would go to a company like Samsung or
whoever and they're already making OLED
displays because that's their technology
and they would make a couple
customizations but that technology can
be sold to anyone else Apple wants to do
all the development and stuff for micro
LED so when they get to the end of the
chain they give the instructions to
someone and they make it but that's an
exclusive Apple technology so they're
kind of trying to get ahead of and own
micro LED so that's why all these stocks
dropped on this news you know when this
reset happens we don't really know which
companies Apple will be going to to
manufacture them Apple's still not going
to make the display themselves and
theoretically it could be the exact same
list of Manufacturers but word on the
street as they're trying to
strategically drop a certain Samsung so
we'll see so that's the displays but
then there's also the story about the
radios which is a little more
interesting because right now they're
buying radios in their phones from
broadcom and Qualcomm but also it's
several different radios and different
parts of the phone so that rumor was not
only that they're going to design their
own chip but that they're going to
combine them all Wi-Fi Bluetooth and
cellular into one chip so that to me is
a little more interesting because
obviously it's the same supply chain
story of oh no if your qualcommer
broadcom you don't really like that
feature but also the possible efficiency
gains because right now there's a bunch
of radios taking up different space in
the phone taking up a bunch of power in
the phone and ideally consolidating all
them to one chip is really great for
efficiency gains maybe it means battery
life gets better so yeah both of these
stories are of Apple using their
mountains of cash to put into The
Upfront development costs and eventually
reap the rewards of better products down
the line for their products that's
essentially what's happening and you
better believe that there's gonna be
other companies who have the same idea
and want to do a sort of a similar thing
they just might not have as much cash so
at the end of the day who does this
affect the most well you can kind of
look at it along the same lines as the
Apple silicon Mac transition so if
you're Apple the main benefit you're
going to get out of this is having a lot
more control which you know Apple loves
that but also being able to have better
products at the end of the day great now
if you're one of the suppliers if you're
Qualcomm or broadcom or Samsung maybe
and you're about to lose a pretty big
customer
yeah then they're going to feel that and
then for us the potential users really
at the end of the day if if they're
successful with this then that means
having better products and maybe we get
mini LED displays starting in apple
watches at first and then maybe in the
iPhone bigger display and then even
bigger ones later cool but also uh it'll
be interesting with the competition with
the the competitive environment and
seeing what companies like Huawei and
xiaomi and Samsung and even Google will
do along the same lines following in
their suit always fun to watch okay
hopefully that helped us all understand
it it helps me thanks for watching catch
you in the next one
[Music]